a lot of people are talking about the
Simpsons right now and for good reason
hey Dad just came for you in the mail an
airborne virus without a vaccine oh and
killer bees which is pretty darn close
to murder Hornets
this 1993 episode eerily mirrors what's
happening today and it's not the first
time the Simpsons has seemingly
predicted the future we've got quite a
track record which is impressive if
you've been on for three decades
probably you're gonna hit it Wow what
people are telling us now is start
predicting some good things five years
before Gaga flew in to perform at the
Super Bowl there was this
one episode forecasted the FIFA arrests
another our current president sixteen
years before there was the prediction
Disney would by 20th Century Fox in this
fire is seen from the finale of Game of
Thrones look the dragon is burning our
village
how would Bart handle quarantine what
would he say to Homer if Homer were to
tell him all right I'm homeschooling you
no way man
dad you know it's quarantine stop stop
none of that makes the same say I feel
like all right I'm gonna make lemonade
lemons here after 31 season since 684
episodes the show must go on even during
a lockdown
each episode takes nine months to
complete and the cast crew and all 500
animators are working from home this is
my recording facility is my microphone
this isn't celeb cameos are well over
800 in this weekend they'll add another
Oscar winner to the list Cate Blanchett
Oh bad
she was recorded about six months ago
she plays a dog psychologist that they
go to and we asked her to do some sort
of nonsense talk to the dog and I swear
she was doing elf language from Lord of
the Rings it's really cool
so who's still on The Simpsons bucket
list of a list gets what about Megan
Markel you know Lee did a voiceover with
Disney floated the balloon it was in the
press but then Harry City wouldn't do
anything that was making fun of the
royal family so that lets that you know
between you and me they have a few
things you can make fun of
[Music]